now to our other top story take a look
at this video the faa
investigating a plane crash in the south
part of town authorities tell us the
cessna went down with two people on
board thank you so much for joining us
on this thursday afternoon
i'm kirsten joyce and i'm denise valdez
so that crash happened around 9
30 near valley view and pebble road we
have live team coverage from the scene
joe moeller is standing by but first
eight news now reporter kate houston
tells us exactly what happened
just moments before that plane went down
kate
yes denise i'm standing in front of the
construction site this is where the
plane crashed
this morning i'm going to step to the
side so you can see this steel wall
behind me
and those dark markings that are spread
across it that's from the fire that
started
directly after the crash here you can
see video of the plane just
moments before it went down it was
flying fairly low
clark county fire says there were only
two people on board the twin
engine cessna 310r it took off from
north las vegas airport this morning
when it crashed it hit that steel wall
and burst
into flames that fire then spread to a
trailer on the other side
where a man was inside bruce langston is
building a home on the property
he tells me he had to crawl on his hands
and knees to get out
because of the fumes i could hear the
propeller
turning over and sounded like a
helicopter
then i heard a thud crash and a gigantic
ball of flames
fuel splashed over my construction
trailer i was in the trailer doing the
work in preparation to finish
building my home and i immediately
recognized
what had happened
the faa and national transportation
safety board are now investigating this
crash
the faa says the plane was headed from
north las vegas to an airport
in san diego now we are working to find
out who exactly was on this plane
and what caused the crash we'll be sure
to give you that information as soon as
we learn more
reporting live tonight from raven and
hinson kate houston 8 news now
all right kate thank you so we are
getting more information here from
eyewitnesses some people living in that
area of the crash tell us
they noticed something just wasn't right
with that plane
joe muller is live with reaction tonight
joe
yeah we spoke to a number of people in
this area who say this plane was flying
very low over raven street here we came
up
on top of our live truck to give you a
better look now take a look at where
this crash happened you can see just how
close it was to that road
this is video shot by matthew lowry he
says he thought the
pilot in the plane was going to jump out
before it crashed because it was so low
he told us he tried to run to the street
and see if he could help anyone inside
but it was already on fire
he knew there was a problem with the
plane because he saw it tilting and says
a propeller was not working like the
other
to angle towards us and then i seen the
guys
the the door to the cabin he opened it
looked like he wanted to jump out
and then uh since the airplane seemed to
come towards us he closed the door and
turned to the other way and that's when
it angled and
it hit that wall i must have been about
150 200 feet from it
several neighbors drove to this area to
see what exactly was going on
all say it was too late when they got
here we spoke to another neighbor who
even thought the plane was going to hit
his home now back out here live you're
taking another look at this plane crash
the investigation ongoing here at this
hour neighbors in this area say
they are completely shocked about this
and they're really curious about what
exactly went wrong inside that plane
and they're wondering what exactly
happened right before this crash to make
it actually crash here throughout the
day we've seen a number of people just
driving by
asking a lot of questions but of course
we'll keep you updated with the latest
information here on 8 news now
reporting live in the southwest valley
till morning 8 news now